I'm a data engineer at simple my twitter
name is at ocean kid Billy and I'm going
to talk about it engineering
architecture I'm gonna focus on a little
bit of Python but a lot of sort of
higher-level work sort of how we've
structured our pipelines how we've built
a data engineering how we use the
warehouse and I'm gonna talk a lot about
mistakes we've made things that we've
learned because we did it wrong the
first time so I have a few examples of
that but what I really want to start
with sort of leading question is why
does simple have a data team like why is
there a data engineering team at symbol
what is our goal within the company
because if you look at engineering as a
whole and like the functional teams it's
pretty clear what all these teams do
right so back-end actually builds core
banking services front-end and mobile
build clients you know if you if you go
to simple comm and sign up for a bank
account and you log on to your app you
know you're interacting with clients
from either front end or our mobile
infrastructure builds you know sort of
core infrastructure helps us ship code
security those security things it's
always good for a bank to have a big
security team so where does data fit
into to all these teams well it turns
out that the rest of the company needs
to answer questions about how the
business is doing with data and and
everyone wants to know like facets of
customer behavior whether it's like
marketing and product trying to figure
out how customers interact with with the
application we have a huge customer
service team they need data to figure
out if they're serving customers well so
the data team we exist to help the
company sort of make decisions and tell
stories with our data so how do we get
this data simple started out with a
service-oriented architecture the
company now runs on more than 35
separate services and almost all those
each have their own Postgres database so
that's a lot of databases right it's a
lot of places to get data from so I'm so
we're gonna pose a question here in a
world without a data team or a data
warehouse what would it look like to
answer a pretty what should be a pretty
simple business question
about our data so we want to find all
the users who have made a transaction
greater than $1 in the past week and in
theory there should be a pretty simple
question for us to answer but what does
this look like without a data warehouse
or a data team so you've got security
production database number one and
you've got scary production database
number two and assuming that your ops
and DBA folks will let you log into your
production databases either that or
they're gonna have to download order
like output this data to CSV for you you
pull it as a CSV you pull it into our
Python you do the join in memory and
then then you go from there that's kind
of a pain that makes a lot of
assumptions about how you get it data
and if you start to answer questions
that are more complex and you've got 35
different databases that you have to do
this for it gets tedious this is how
simply used to work in the early days
this is how like the the young beta team
which was two people worked they would
do dumps from from production and and do
their work and Python some ones that
look like when you have a data warehouse
well if all of those databases are in
one warehouse it's a pretty pretty
straightforward sequel statement and
it's just it's just a regular joint so
the data warehouse lets us collapse 35
individual DB's each for a separate
service and to essentially one database
to the analyst it just looks like a
database so were they the engineers and
the business through dashboards you know
dashboards that work with sequel there
are a lot of dashboarding tools so that
they appreciate having all the data in
one place and we have controls over that
in terms of permissions the warehouse
lets us get data to everyone from one
place so what does data engineering do
we build the tools and systems to make
data available to everyone who needs it
so that that is our job and our data
warehouse of choice is redshift so I'm
going to talk a little bit about
redshift and what it is sort of what
we've learned while using it and sort of
some pointers for using redshift if you
choose it as your data warehouse of
choice so to start with why would you
want to use redshift like why use
redshift and not a dupe or some other
some other data store one of the biggest
ones honestly is its sequel right it was
it was fort from Postgres at 8.2 so you
know it's more or less just sequel if
you know sequel you can query redshift
it's got incredibly fast load times from
s3 so using s3 is like an intermediate
intermediate stage to get data into
redshift which is something we do a lot
is incredibly fast it's got very fast
query times redshift is really fast if
you model your data correctly which
we'll get to in a minute
the security model is the same as the
rest of AWS s security model so you can
leverage like I am and Paroles and that
sort of thing to give people permission
to get in and one of the biggest things
is that the rest of simple all runs on
ec2 and runs on AWS so sort of a
no-brainer for us right like we already
have services running an ec2 we already
have data stored in s3 redshift was a
pretty clear choice as a warehouse for
us so here's a wallet text and this is a
wall of text written by the Amazon
redshift documentation writer talking
about the database and it's a little
business sea but I think there's
actually some good things in here and
I'm gonna walk through sort of these
these highlighted lines so enterprise
class relational database Korean
management system massively parallel
processing columnar data storage
targeted data compression so this reads
like you know sort of a business line
but these things are actually really
important to how you use the warehouse
so let's talk about enterprise class
relational database query and management
system it quacks like in a sequel
database right it looks like any other
sequel database like I said it was for
it from postgrads 8.2 there are some
functions that aren't available that are
in Postgres but for the most part it
complies with the sequel standard the
JDBC and ODBC connectors that you
already have work out of the box for the
most part which is really nice
so a lot of my work and redshift happens
to be a psycho PG to write the Python
connector it just works with redshift
it's totally fine
the query language like I said it looks
a little different but it's pretty close
so massively parallel processing what
does that mean so if you if you stand up
a post grants Postgres instance you've
got like one node database right you
have a Postgres instance you have like
an ec2 box or RDS it's one instance of
Postgres redshift is parallel so it
splits your data amongst many compute
nodes so you distribute your data across
a bunch of nodes and within those nodes
there's split among what they call
slices which is allocated alike
portion of the nodes memory and disk
space so redshift can parallelized both
data storage and data queries and part
of that parallelization is with these
things called disk keys and sort keys so
redshift not only allows you but forces
you to decide and think about how your
data is both distributed and sorted and
this can make a huge difference in your
query times and and how effective
redshift is to you as a database so I'm
gonna come take a look at this create
statement so this looks a lot like a
normal like Postgres create table
statement you'll notice that we have to
specify an encoding so a compression
encoding at the end and then in this
case we're gonna distribute the data by
user ID you can assume it's a UID and
we're gonna sort the data by wind record
it so it's often really useful to have
your data sorted by timestamp so ya
redshift emphasizes the use of these two
keys to specify both distribution and
sordidness and you can leave them out
but if you do leave them out redshift
will make some assumptions for you and
those assumptions might result in your
queries being quite slow so performance
good supper if you don't think about
them so let's look at an example so in
that create table example what we did
was we we distributed the data by user
ID so you know user ID one every every
all pieces of data that come in with
user ID one are going to compute another
one and all pieces of data that come in
with user ID to we're going to compute
no to same for three because redshift is
doing like hash space partitioning
partitioning on user ID to go to the
different nodes but this is actually
something that we saw in production when
you're like alright well we're using a
new IDs it should be very evenly
distributed well we noticed that one
node was just like growing and growing
we were getting really close to the
limit of disk on that box and like what
is happening um so this is what was
happening
so we got a we had a lot of messages
come through with user ID equals null
and these weren't invalid data like this
was actually valid data just sometimes
for this particularly use case there is
no user ID attached so we had to
recreate the table and redistribute the
data so this is the new table where we
said all right the disk key is even so
basically we're going to distribute the
data evenly across all nodes which fixes
our problem with disk space but actually
started to make some queries slower and
this is like I mean this is how it looks
now this is a trade-off that we had to
make because now before if all user IDs
for a given user ID lived on a single
node when you needed to join two tables
together that join can happen on that
node just on that node now that we've
distributed user IDs across the whole
cluster those joins require shuffles
across all notes so we saw some grades
get slower and we fixed our disk problem
but you know our analysts you know also
note you know notice that some some
craze were slowed down a little bit so
it requires trade-offs and this is one
that this is one that we saw in
production so here's another one that we
saw I'm going to talk about sort keys so
so data dated sordidness so in this case
I'm joining two tables based on based on
user ID and distribution aside if your
if your data is not sorted if you don't
have a sort key on this what it's gonna
do is it's gonna create a hash join so
this if you've never used the explained
query and Postgres the red shift it
tells you exactly how it's going to
execute your query and is really useful
in figuring out all right my query is
slow why is my query slow so in this
case we're joining the Gov the
transactions table with the goals table
the goals tables going to be the smaller
one so we're gonna build a hash table
with a goals table and then the join the
two together we're gonna probe it you
know as we walk through the transactions
table and we learned that in redshift
your hash table for join cans built a
disk not only can it's built a disk it
can fill up all the available disk space
on your cluster and it can cause the
entire cluster to go down we had this
happen more than once before we fixed it
we still we still see it get close these
days red shift has query timeouts but
they're not on by default so if you're
running a red shift
Riley recommends setting some sort of
reasonable timeout for your query else
this happens because this is like a very
real use case you don't have to have
that much data before you start building
these giant hash tables for joins and
start seeing them spill the disk and
suddenly you see your disk usage
basically go to 100% on multiple nodes
so to move on in this example here's an
interesting fix so redshift lets you
create temp tables and it's actually
really cheap and fast to create empty
temp tables that have different data
distributions and different data sort
keys so in this case we're creating two
temp tables one of transactions on the
goals both distributed by user ID and
both sorted by user ID so now when we do
the join the query plan actually does
emerge join which can not only which can
basically be streamed in memory and it's
really fast it's it's amazing it's
faster it's been faster for us to create
a temp table where we get merged joined
behavior than to then just like to ask
join like even if even if it's not
spilling the disk merge joins and
redshift are so so fast so this is an
example of where like thinking about
sort keys is really important in your
queries so back to the the business
speak columnar data storage so I think
this was touched on a little bit in the
feather talk earlier if you're if you
have a columnar database and your query
and columnar databases you really want
to try to avoid all select star from
queries you always want to limit only
the columns that you're actually working
with and the reason for that is the way
that Postgres stores data is it stores
it row wise right so if you select a and
B from the table and it's just like
select a be all a baby you have to do a
full table scan so with Postgres you're
doing a full table scan you're throwing
away everything but a and B but it's the
only way to get it all of a and B it has
to scan all rows red ship doesn't store
data in rows and stores data in columns
so when you select a and B all it has to
do is fetch the columns a and B from
disk so the more select so it you know
in this case like if you do a select
star unless you really need all that
data you're throwing everything away in
terms of i/o so always try to limit how
many columns you're selecting so now
we're gonna talk about compression so
redshift has very efficient targeted
data compression encoding schemes
so redshift I think by default it won't
encourage your data but you can select
an encoding for your data to compress it
a really nice thing that redshift will
do if you already have data in a table
you can run analyze compression and
redshift will take some subset of that
data and recommend a compression for you
which is really nice quick caveat that
coming and that sequel call analyze
compression requires a like a full table
lock so I would not recommend doing this
for a table where your act like actively
loading data or serving queries because
it will lock that table until it is done
compression is really important for
redshift especially like keeping your
disk sizes like keeping your disk
reasonable it improves both query
performance and storage overhead so it
improves query performance because if
you're pulling in code like IO if you're
pulling encoded data off disk that's
much faster than on encoded data and
then of course is improved your storage
overhead right because you're storing
less data on disk I give a short
lightning talk and call them a
compression if you're interested in how
redshift encodes data there's a lot
information there there are a lot of
really clever tricks that redshift uses
for different types so that's there on
github so now sort of the grab-bag of
important operational notes things we've
learned while using redshift the first
one being that redshift supports
redshift as an acid compliant database
it supports fully serializable isolation
levels and like okay what does that mean
for me like running redshift it means
that transactions can be kind of
expensive and the commit queue for
transactions can backup so if you're
thinking oh I'm gonna I'm gonna stream
data into rich if I'm gonna load data
into redshift every minute that probably
won't work because we tried it we tried
loading data like every three to five
minutes and we had to back it off to
about ten except for critical tables
because we found that like with our creo
load and all these loads happening or
committee was backing up so remember
this when you're thinking about loading
data to redshift and trying to stream
data in do that uh redshift has a
maintenance window right redshift has a
maintenance window every week probably
like 2 a.m. ours is 2 a.m. on Monday if
you're building systems that require
uptime systems that expect redshift to
be up systems that have health checks
and might page an engineer in the middle
of the night if redshift goes down
highly recommend building those systems
to be resilient resilient to this
maintance window
we still haven't fit we got page for
this
last week like we're still uh once in
while we still get paged for a
maintenance window because there's some
system that doesn't account for properly
redshift so var car is a common data
type in sequel databases
redshift lets you specify of our car max
which is basically var car 65,535 bytes
and you think why would I ever specify
something that big well the answer is
because Postgres has a text type and you
can put about as much as data as you
want in the Postgres text to type and a
lot of people use it and that translates
most closely to this var car max type
but it's really expensive some joins
won't work you'll get errors like air
8001 detail the combined length of
columns process in the sequel statement
exceeded the query processing limit of
6535 characters stuff like that so when
you're thinking about VAR car max
remember it can be pretty sensitive when
doing joins and then the last one is
redshift is a black box once so
basically they ship software updates so
we're like in the Google Chrome an or
they just accept they do even worse than
that they just ship them behind the
scenes like you never know when redshift
is updating it just updates right and
like they've broken the Cory planer on
us only once but it happened we had a
query that just stopped working because
the query pointer broke and when
redshift goes down so this is this is
good and bad right when redshift goes
down there's something you can do you
just have to wait for Amazon to fix it
so it's bad because redshift is down
it's good because like you're not the
one fighting the fire so it's a pretty
big trade-off but like I have this on
here but honestly redshift has been
incredibly stable for us like it it has
gone down and very rarely I can count on
one hand the number of times we've seen
it go down and when I say go down I mean
for a period of ten or fifteen minutes
it's usually when some sort of node
fails and they have to replace a node so
see our queries look like Postgres
redshift is fork from Postgres but it's
not post Breaston you need to remember
that Metheny about like distributed
nature and it's a tribute nature when
like building tables and queries so a
word Python conference what are the ways
that you can talk to redshift with
Python there's sort of the venerable
psycho PG to library that library can
kind of be a pain to install if you've
ever tried to install that library
especially if you've tried to install it
with like SSL it can be it can be kind
of painful there's a
brand-new Python 3 point 5 plus pure
Python PostgreSQL async PG that I
haven't used yet but it's supposed to be
incredibly fast and and looks quite good
and we might we might look at starting
to switch some of our psycho PG 2 uses
to that and for our analyst if at travel
trouble installing psycho PG 2 we might
start pointing them at async PG there's
a sequel alchemy dialect for redshift
that sort of built on top of the
existing sequel alchemy stuff with some
redshift specific operators and then
finally we at simple we have an open
source library to interact with redshift
called shift manager and it's got its
like a bunch of helpers like some for
creating users doing schema reflection
which helps like deep copies of tables
deepa duplication migrations and then
poorly documented but in there there are
some tools for doing bulk loads of data
from Postgres to redshift and the same
thing with bulk json we'd probably need
to write some Doc's but they're in there
if you go look at the code so if you're
working with redshift you might find
some useful some useful stuff in there
alright so let's talk about simples
pipelines this is the entirety of
simples data pipeline so boxes with
borders are our services and then
everything else is sort of connective
tissue so Kafka rabbit and queue message
brokers things holding state like s3
redshift elasticsearch and that sort of
thing so this is kind of an eye chart so
let's walk through what each of these
things does for us so we have a service
called salt tooth it's old it's it's
basically Postgres replication and that
we crawl Postgres on a schedule like
every 10 or 15 minutes and then you
zookeeper to store the timestamps for
the last crawl and when we crawl it we
fetch like the last 15 minutes of data
we put that the rabid mq that goes to
redshift we have some really tricky bugs
in this library around the updates of
ROS we found though doing this can be a
little tricky when you have a lot of row
updates and sometimes we have some
tables with like poor data models where
it's not clear when the when the row is
updated and so we found some subtle bugs
in here and we're moving away of this
away from this towards a more robust
solution that we call PG Kafka so in
Postgres 9.4
plus there's this new feature where you
can
you can basically that's called logical
replication slots and what that does is
you can have Postgres stream every
change in the database to something and
for us that's the Kafka like message
queue right so it's more or less a
real-time stream of the right ahead log
to two Kafka so every update every
insert every delete all these comes
through the Kafka and then downstream
talked a little bit about how they get
into redshift right now I'm working on a
question that I've gotten before is okay
when engineers in the backend team make
changes to the Postgres database how do
you know those changes are reflected in
redshift and right now the answer is an
analyst realizes that something is
missing comes and talks to us and we
have to backfill data the answer in the
future is going to be we can also
replicate DDL statements like create
table and alter table downstream and
apply those to downstream databases
we're obviously not going to do this
with destructive statements
I think automatically applying the leak
table and delete column statements to be
very bad so that's not gonna happen that
anything additive we're working on on
streaming those downstream here's the
grab bag of things like I think any data
engineering team you eventually end up
just like with this pile of things that
have to handle different things for the
business so you've got a service that
handles data transformation we've got a
service that handles emails so anytime a
customer like signs up and we need to
send them live cycling emails you've got
a service that does that we're folding
some of these things into one sort of
big service called estuary that is built
on kafka streams and will let us supply
let us build like individual jobs and
sort of have all this one place in one
place it's really tough to manage
multiple services everyone is sort of
like is a weight on the team and in
terms of being on-call and that sort of
thing and then finally we've got a
service that handles user events from
client so every time like you interact
with simple on your phone or on the web
it sends events into this HTTP endpoint
those go into redshift all right so
let's talk about I've talked a lot about
putting data onto message queues how do
we get that data from the message queues
into redshift we have a service called
horizon that's like our ETL service so
we read from both Kafka and RabbitMQ we
batch those messages and put them to s3
and then we have a loader that loads
those batches from s3
to redshift one kind of neat piece that
we have is it'll take a batch redshift
has this thing called a no load copy
where you can attempt a copy against
redshift and it'll tell you if it's
pass/fail like hey this copy that you're
gonna try to do works or hey this failed
if we have a batch that fails we'll
start bisecting that batch and extract
the bad messages out and put them to s3
for something to happen in the future
right now that something is they're just
sitting there and like none of us
actually wants to go deal with it like
you know they're there for the future
and so that's basically it got a batcher
we got a loader we've got like six or
seven instances of horizon running at
the same time loading from s3 into
redshift so we use do keeper to keep a
table lock so those instances talk to
zookeeper and say hey are you learning
the transact is the transaction table
being loaded right now yeah okay I'm
gonna move on load a different table so
zookeepers like our locking mechanism so
all the instances of horizon can load in
parallel one decision this happened
before I actually showed up that it was
made sort of early on about the data
schema that I thought was really smart
is this is all that it takes to send
data to redshift you need a table name
and you need a datum with column like
key value pairs with a column name and
then a value and so if you want to put
data in redshift at simple all you need
to do is create the table horizon we'll
pick up that table because horizon
queries redshift like every 10 minutes
for table schemas so create the table in
redshift after 10 minutes horizon will
pick it up put it in a schema registry
and then any data sent to horizon it'll
automatically start loading that data in
a redshift
so you don't have to do a bunch of
fiddling between you and redshift you
just say alright I'm gonna create the
table I'm gonna start sending the data
to the cube that horizon consumes from
and boom we're done moving on to a
couple of our other services we also
have a transaction start service so if
you sign up for a simple account right
now and you spend some money and you go
to search of transactions and you see
some analytics and that sort of thing
that's all served by a service from the
data team it's ingesting from Kafka
putting to elasticsearch and then it
serves HTTP requests from clients and
mobile and then finally our our biggest
Python service at some point somebody
said what we really need is like a janky
version of cron and at that point Jiang
cron was born and what Jack Rhonda does
is like purely run scheduled tasks
basically scheduled tasks to get data
from third parties
and put it into redshift so we pull beta
from like our email our third-party
email provider we pull data from
mannequins we actually pull a lot of
github data so well we run github
enterprise and every night we pull
everything that happened in github that
day and put it in a redshift so that our
our business folks can like sort of look
our engineering leadership can sort of
look at how we're working on github and
that's our thing and that's actually
been a pretty fun one that's pretty fun
data to analyze um so those are all the
pipes that that's all of simple simple
data engineering so what have we learned
from building all of this the first one
is that we're moving away the whole
company is moving from RabbitMQ to kafka
RabbitMQ was in place like when simples
started we're transitioning to Kafka why
are we doing that so one reason is Kafka
has this idea of a retention period so
you can tell Kafka how long to hold on
to your data and at anytime let's say
that your service fails goes down for
some period of time
Kafka stores the last offset that you
store from that date and like you can go
back in time at any point from Kafka
right like you can say hey I advanced
all the way to offset 2,000,000 but I
need to go back to like offset 1 million
500 let's go back and replay all this
data through through the pipeline I mean
that's super valuable whereas with
rabbit like if you act a message like
you got that message you better not drop
it the other thing is Kafka actually has
like real Network partition tolerance
we've had instances in the past where
rabbit like and to be fair to rabbit
like rabbit is very clear in the
documentation up front does not tolerate
network partitions well like first line
in the documentation what happens if two
rabbit nodes stopped talking to one
another
basically the one node that got
separated like I'm in a bad state you
need to fix me and by fixing me I mean
you need to drain those messages
manually to like your computer and then
put them back through your pipeline by
hand and that didn't happen too often
but when it did it was kind of a big
deal
and then super painful so the next one
is metrics and health checks I just
talked about a bunch of services there
are a ton of moving parts to keep track
of if you don't have your services
instrumented with metrics and health
checks deployment is scary you don't
know when your stuff is broken it's
really hard to know like the health of
your systems without having these things
in place flask and Django both have
libraries that support metrics and
health checks and honestly I'd never
written anything with any HTTP service
with a metric or health check before
I got to simple but all of mine in the
future will have them because I think
they're really important to knowing like
observability for your systems is really
important like knowing the health of
your systems is incredibly important
Postgres it's a really good default it's
a great data store what do you need like
relational JSON key value it's a great
solution well you should also you should
be flexible right so in the in the case
of like doing transaction search elastic
search which is built on Lucene has a
lot more flexibility in terms of NLP you
can scale a better the scaling story for
Postgres with full-text search wasn't
quite clear and the query capabilities
were a bit more limited so I always tell
people like default to Postgres but in
certain specific use cases you might you
might need to look at other databases I
mentioned this earlier the flexibility
of our data model with horizon is made
scaling our redshift schema a lot easier
and along with that table migration
tools for redshift have made schema
Mangin management easier we use a
flyaway which is a java library but if
you haven't used Olympique for python
which is a table migration library I
think it's written by the same person
who did sequel alchemy it's really good
if you're doing your migrations database
migrations by hand you should take a
look at it because it's just a really
nice software practice to have celery
the task queue the Python task queue I
love celery we used before simple I use
celery we used celery at simple all the
ETL jobs that we have are most of them
that aren't streaming our batch jobs so
we didn't really need airflow airflow is
out at that point who said we don't we
don't have any tags like we don't have
any we don't need a graph of jobs
they're just like scheduled batch jobs
you really need something that looks a
lot like cron but lets you write your
jobs in Python because we had analysts
writing jobs so celery was great and
celery continues to work well for us so
ok this is PI data I'm gonna I'm gonna
talk a little bit more about Python
because confession most of simple runs
on the JVM a lot of our services are
written in Scala job and closure and
that's because the company one of the
cofounders of simple came from was an
early Twitter engineer and and like all
third of Scala book right but a lot of
our engineers use Python every day for
data science analysis ETL connecting
databases I think every single a JVM
service I've
and has a Python script in the root to
do something whether it's like low
testing or like smoke testing or
something like that I end up using
Python for all of my scripting work and
the other thing is you can build our
entire pipeline with Python running JVM
services like zookeeper and Kafka
doesn't mean that you need to interact
with them with jvm languages right so
there are some really good libraries out
there written in Python to interact with
these JVM tools so you don't need to be
writing Java you can write Python and
there are some companies company called
parsley that does this there are they're
streaming billions of messages through
Python services with Python libraries
like these so there's a really good
zookeeper library called kazoo we use
pica and Python Kafka to talk to
RabbitMQ and Kafka within our celery
task worker there's a really good blog
post at benchmarks the Kafka clients and
they they're really good you can get a
huge volume through the Python clients
and then the last thing elasticsearch so
we have this search service I think
elastic search and dynamic languages are
really perfect for one another this is
an example of what it's like to write a
query and elastic search in Java
basically it's one big string and then
you have like a string builder and
multiple builders and you basically have
to do string manipulation to build
queries that's so painful whereas in a
language like Python it's elastic search
takes JSON so it's just a dictionary
right you can basically compose and come
by and dictionaries that represent
concrete ideas about queries together
using Python to build your query so I
think when working with elastic serves
like dynamic languages are they the way
to go when working with it and that's it
that's all I've got you have any
questions
yeah we do so the infrastructure team oh
yeah yes if we have systems for setting
up the infrastructure yes so we work
with Amazon's cloud formation and we
have some sort of helper libraries to
work with cloud formation and build
templates to set up our systems so we
have cloud formation and Jenkins running
the data I'm very lucky I don't have to
build those systems we have an
infrastructure team that like sets up
the deployment like their job is to make
it easier for us to set stand-up new
services so for us it's you know go go
change the CloudFormation template let
him know that we're building this thing
that sort of thing so the question was
do we hire do we hire entry level data
engineers
I think simples engineering staff is
pretty top-heavy to be honest we have
very few junior engineers and I hope
that changes I think we need to hire
more I came in to simple never having
written a single line of code that runs
in the JVM right so I knew Python pretty
well I knew javascript pretty well but I
don't have to learn Scala and that sort
of thing and I think there's I think
there to be honest there used to be more
flexibility for that I think we're
actually gonna focus more on junior
developers you know coming soon as we
get bigger I think as an organization
gets big enough like you can't keep
hiring senior developers the whole time
like I feel like you sort of owe it to
like the community to hire juniors and
sort of build them up into seniors so
the answer is I hope we get better at it
yep
oh yeah yep so the question was how do
we use segment segment comm I'm a very
complex relationship with segment comm
we use them the thing is that marketing
and business folks often want to use
various analytics providers and and ad
like ad serving providers and that sort
of thing so we have a lot basically our
clients pipe all of their like the
client interactions all go through
segment first and then come through
segments web hooks to us for us to put
in a redshift and then once they're in
segment the marketing people can send
them to whatever third party integration
they want all of our email integration
goes through segment first so we send
dated a segment and then they send it to
exact target or email provider and sorry
what was your second question
Oh anecdotal data volumes um so what I
say what I say about simple is simple
doesn't have big data so we don't have a
bunch of data where we can like we don't
have a huge data stream where we can
afford to drop a little bit we've got a
small data stream where we can afford to
drop nothing right because we're a bank
you can't drop transactions that's very
bad
so I mean to give you an example like
our search service you know we're
getting you know ten or ten or fifteen
you know messages a second and other
services I think our highest volume
service like we're in the hundreds right
we're not we're not having to deal with
thousands tens of thousands you know
millions of messages a second so it's a
really nice problem like it's nice not
having huge piles of data but we sort
have different problems to solve because
we can't really afford to drop any of it
so we have to have really really
resilient systems all right all right
thank you
you